you
the aim of the Bratislava summit is to
bring back the political control of our
common future the Union and its member
states must address the major concerns
and worries of its citizens uncontrolled
irregular migration terrorism and the
fears of globalization together we have
made much progress since the biggest
migratory wave towards Europe started
last year the total number of irregular
migrants arriving to Greece from Turkey
in the last four month it's the same as
in a single day in October last year
never again should we allow the chaos of
2015 to repeat in Europe
the brothers lava summit is not about
Rex each person our goal is to regain
the sense that globalization is an
opportunity and not a threat we will be
open to the outside world but always
bearing in mind the best interest of our
own citizens
securing the rights of EU citizens
living in the UK will also be a key
objective for us and to this equally
clear that our future relationship is
the UK requires a balance of rights and
obligations any access to the single
market must be based on the four
freedoms including the freedom of
movement